we have breaking news overnight in the
fight over the new voting law in georgia
baseball's all-star game
will reportedly be held at denver's
coors field that is the home of the
colorado rockies after the league pulled
out of atlanta
ed o'keefe is following this from
washington ed is both a baseball fan and
he knows politics so good morning to you
what's behind the decision
well good morning tony we're waiting for
a formal announcement from mlb today but
the league has said it opposes
restrictions
at the ballot box and in terms of access
colorado is one of the easiest states to
vote in it sends mail-in ballots to
every voter in the state
with a 95 percent return rate the state
had the highest second highest turnout
in the presidential election
while georgia's law does expand access
to early voting statewide
it shrinks the window for sending
absentee ballots limits the number of
ballot drop boxes and gives more control
of elections to georgia's lawmakers who
are majority republican
a number of corporations are joining
major league baseball in condemning
georgia's new law including american
airlines
and two atlanta-based companies delta
airlines and coca-cola
that's led some republicans to call for
boycotts of those companies and
mlb and in a sign of the growing rift
between republicans and big companies on
monday
even senate minority leader mitch
mcconnell urged corporations to quote
stay out of politics and that they could
face unspecified quote serious
consequences
if they keep engaging in these kinds of
fights anthony
ed o'keefe a washington nationals fan
which we will not hold against
thank you ed